dave is with us in dallas hi dave
welcome to the ramsay show how can we
help
hey dave i'm uh trying to determine
whether or not i should
do a deferred income annuity
why would you do that well
my financial person
suggested it because i'm i'm real
fearful fearful of the
other market crash and
she's like well you know if the market
crashes you know the
he's losing the value of of our
retirement right now i'm
i'm retired uh my wife is fixing to
retire
[Music]
and you're fearful that the market is
going to completely destroy
well not completely but uh you know
half and then if i'm withdrawing
and where in history have you seen it do
that
okay uh you're right you're right uh or
30 i guess and where in history have you
seen it do that
i thought 2008 was somewhere around
there no it was half
the dow went from 13 to 6 700. okay
and it was back in a year right right
and now it's not 6700 or 13 it's 30 000
right
correct okay so unless you have a need
for 2.5 million dollars at the bottom of
the market
you would not embrace the 30 percent
loss you would ride it out wouldn't you
yes even though i'm going to be
withdrawing
you know 10 grand a month which is a
whole hundred and twenty thousand
dollars a year
that's not even the growth okay
okay dave listen yes sir listen my
friend
you are an everyday millionaire you have
been intentional in growing this money
you're going to be fine i listen
the thing is this okay i understand
that the world is unraveling out here in
front of us i'm watching it too
i'm not disagreeing with you about that
but we we
dr daloni talks about when we're in a
crisis situation or when we're in a
situation
facts are our friends not fear
and if the facts say if there's some
actual facts that indicate that we're
going to have a substantial market drop
and it's going to maintain and it's
going to stay down there
then we would have this discussion i
don't have any of those
facts the only thing i've got is i don't
like the socialist
tendencies that are in dc right now
i don't like the idea of heavy taxation
i don't like what they're going to do to
the economy
uh overall i don't think it's going to
be pleasant but i don't think we're
going
to see a market correction of 30 percent
i'm 60 i have pulled zero
out of the market due to my being upset
about the current world that i live in
does that make sense
yes so while i have those emotions i
have to gauge the actual
facts of the history to do that so
all of that said i'm not sure i would do
a deferred income annuity i might do a
variable annuity and a variable annuity
will give you principal protection
and a floor of a minimum gain
or minimum increase in value usually
five percent six percent
and you're invested in vehicles that are
going to make you 10 to 12.
on average but if the market really
tanked you'd have principal protection
and you would have a
you know a floor for the earnings and so
if if that will make you sleep better at
night
you're going to pay an extra fee for
that
variable annuity that you really don't
need it doesn't give you anything that
you need
except that peace of mind that you're
looking for so you're paying for that
now would i move the whole two million
dollars in there absolutely not
but but what i move in your case if you
still
think this through and you still are
worried about it uh
you know then you know you might move
500 700 in there maybe move a third of
your
of your net worth into that it's not a
bad place because you can put it in good
mutual funds you'll still have a similar
growth rate
you're just going to have a higher
expense ratios okay
and when you pull money out of it it's
no longer going to be taxed at
uh well it's it's in it's all in 401ks
anyway isn't it
correct yeah you're going to be tax
ordinary income anyway when you come out
but um well no oh i'm sorry uh
right now no mine's not in 401ks
all of mine is or the majority of mine
is in irs okay
but if you have non you see you're taxed
at ordinary income when you pull it out
of a traditional ira
and so when you pull it out of this
you're going to be tax ordinary income
too so that doesn't harm you much
if you're dealing with non-retirement
money putting into a variable annuity
you're going to
change from capital gains taxation to
ordinary income taxation which is
something else to consider but that's
not your case yeah
so maybe a third of it dave but the
other thing i would do is i'd spend some
more time
learning about history and let facts be
your friends
even though we're scared